hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge aus dem germain ja die stars
ananas und ich geh jetzt weg warb doch
super
das sieht einfach gar nichts ja wenn ihr
die letzte folge gesehen habe denkt ihr
euch was ist da schiefgelaufen komme war
so fertig hat mir irgendwie die tonspur
fakt aber ich hatte nie verkauft mein
weihnachtswunsch vorweg und wir müssen
ein schlüssel finden und ich habe mich
dann mein wenig informiert abgefunden
dass man ja hier einfach her laufen kann
und so war haben wir einfach nicht
gefunden wir sind also mancher übersieht
man sich suchen da sein schlüssel über
album der kletterten auf bäume hoch ganz
version
was hatte gekommen wenn er mal sein
abendessen sucht aber sonst nichts ja
was auch noch die schneller dann auch
die bäume bestreikte komme der am haus
der kommt besteigen europe dass das mal
in goma frank rommel motors co so ist es
gar nicht mehr im chat tätig konkret
akrobatik
aber egal ich will ja nicht ich gehe
jetzt mal gestorben
wir müssen jetzt kommen wir sagen jetzt
mal diese folge komplett ohne tpk die
sorge wird es möglich sein meine damen
und herren ich wette dagegen die spanier
wird es dann laut deswegen sollte
einfach um zu gewinnen jetzt die wette
mich einfach die pläne tp von crafter
zakir wurde sind um was für die wette
geben sich geschafft ich habe gerade
gesagt werden
aber das war meine steuern ich freue
mich nicht tippen kann man nämlich hat
das machst du ja okay ich gebe jetzt ein
wort ep mich diese folge kein mal auch
wenn ich wieder von anfang an starten
muss durch eigene fehler
okay okay du wenn du mich du kennst ich
bin pvp pro du dich auf dich töten
du bist gleich wieder ton oder einfach
nach oben bist du denkst du willst dich
zu mir teleportieren aber nein erschießt
mich ab
mit einem schuss war einfach die kräfte
kräfte der kann ich von hier irgendwie
darüber nicht töten das ist ja das
bringt den jump kraft
und kein träumer ach mensch du bist echt
kacke ich finde eigentlich mal ganz
entspannend wenn man wirklich mal kein
frontrunner buckley wo hast du
eingemottet sieht die folge nicht eine
etage über die ich bin selber jetzt ganz
oben bei der diamanten schicht jetzt auf
einmal hätte das sogar sein lack und
findet auf einmal gas drehen oder sowohl
sie gar nicht gibt hier im lande ich das
so aus vor allem haben sie gesagt ja ich
gucke ein bisschen oben guckt ist in rom
kommen findet es einfach nicht da bist
du auf der diamant schicht da bin ich
auch und jetzt weiß wieso eigentlich ein
bogen ich habe ich dich in skelett
gefunden habe ich meine die clubs darauf
dich umzubringen
oliver schätzle ich es mir gleich bei
den zuschauer ich mache jetzt bieten
du weißt dass eni schafften gleich mit
spricht kommt er kommt
ach das ist ja druck das ist ja druck
wenn es an kraft ankommt dann hat man
natürlich sagen nein das ist auch in
asien
das schafft man nicht ohne sprit
zufrieden bist du sagst du
sportlich würde ich niemals töten
ich lasse jetzt sogar mal vorbei ich
denke unter druck situation bist du gut
dass ich schenk dir sogar was er nimmt
das einfach nicht an
ich stell mir genau deswegen läufst du
dich gegen blaue anfang also ich also da
wo wir gestartet haben heute erfolgt
ja klar du bist bestimmt hinter mir
deswegen war es ja gerade so gemein von
dir deswegen fühle ich mich richtig
angegriffen
manchmal denke ich mir diesen komme den
kann man einfach einfach mehr kohle colo
colo colo colo colo colo so hier die
unnötig war das eis bringt da gar nix da
gar nix was bringt denn dieses eis was
macht das ein wenig daraus
phoenix ist beschleunigt ich wenn du
darüber läuft denn er war das ist so alt
und ich muss immer das eis spring aber
wenn man auf heiß drauf hält passiert
doch gar nichts
ich hol dich noch ein sag ich dir ich
fahre jetzt auch auf die stufe japan
bestimmt bestehe ich warte jetzt
wirklich auf dich erlaubt auf ruhig
weiter kräfte
ich habe damit der probleme nicht dauern
ich glaube weg warst du mich eine
abkürzung
ich wünsche dir bei diesem job machen
ich finde das immer geil mit seiner
extra text speck dafür gemacht wird und
außerdem leute wenn ihr irgendwelche
maps habt dann könnt ihr die uns auch
schreiben meine wurst ausgeschlossen
bilder aber richtig lessing hat die
grossen rat in einem lauf ohne spaß ich
habe diese ganze folge ohne sterben ich
betone tief in der höhle
ich warte doch nicht auf dich alter er
manchmal sei sie manchmal ist das leben
schon wirklich hart da gebe ich dir
recht du ich sagte ich finde den weg wie
ich auch ohne dp da wieder hinkommen
naja über die sprünge vielleicht ja ich
glaub ich hab wirklich weg es gibt nur
einen weg machen es gibt nur einen weg
man aber keine weg frei dimdim team
wartet bin ich hier
was steht eigentlich aufgestellt hier
ist nur kohle ohne spaß ja wirklich weg
zurück gefunden ohne tpk ich will so
ihrem boot ohne spaß night guck dir
nachher allerdings an meine folge
ich habe weg zurück von ohne tpk einfach
ein paar blöcke lang gesprungen doch
wirklich die map ist fast sicherheit
angeht nicht so gut aufgebaut aber und
ich weiß jetzt nicht im ernst wir vor
vier oder doch ich bin wieder bei den
lava springen da wo ich einmal stolz
da würde ich vorhin gestorben bin ja
jetzt bin ich in einem urwald in seinem
dschungel achten ist wenn mario sprünge
hinweg war wie schon lange schon seit
zehn jahren
okay okay
und tu berlin jump in die pull down der
ok wir sollten den pool springen
aber ich warte mal lustig oder erpressen
44 so bleibst du immer gleich da ich bin
hier beim dschungel mensch ich mal
wieder kräftig schmeißt er einen weg
dahin der kommen ist doch fest der hat
wenn der bürger sieht dann springt er
gleich viel besser
geil bürger um 0.36 shopping.com betten
geil
gute nacht ach ja ein guter name gute
nacht
ich wünsche ein herr sich das war's denn
die hatte neben dir im rating du dackel
terrier hey training minecraft
especially when you say das casting
judith von sponsored the secret an on
stage 1
in der jungle bisher geschafft ja ich
hab's auch bisher ohne tp geschafft so
musste ich dann gelang ganz am anfang
habe ich mich einmal tp da brauch ich
bin hier falsch wie ehrlich ja das tier
wieder jumps gegeben
ich bin ja mal dieser dritter lewis ist
okay euro von craft hat sich auch
shampoos gegeben er brachte ja gar
nichts ich springe einfach so ich so
direkt von block 3 auch das richtig
traurig aus april kräftig abgespeckt so
halten block hoch betreut uns bestimmen
darf halt bei der epic ganz geil da wir
haben drei punkte das ist da halt auch
der vorteil wäre mir gar keinen sinn
denn sonst hätte ich auch nicht gewartet
oder so aber das hat echt cool dass man
man wartet soundso obwohl keiner von uns
beide wartet doch ich hab schon auf dich
gewartet ja bestimmen da ich hab gesagt
du musst gar nicht warten alter nett ist
ich werde dich fällt dann weg wie ich da
wieder hochkomme ja aber ja ich hab ich
habe wieder weg gefunden aufgebaut
arschloch ich auf männer kommen weder in
das man ohne trocken
ohne spaß immer wieder tötet
teleportiert du dich aber wenn ich nicht
wenn du mich wichtige portieren ja ich
habe mir noch gar nicht teleportieren
autos jetzt kommt noch ein zombie an
das leben was will goldener rüstung an
aber der keine mx der pusher so verdammt
nicht mehr runter gefallen kann ich gar
nicht
warte halt nicht okay war halt nicht
ich warte doch auch einen kleinen
vorsprung ich meine du bist doch der
ober jump profi habe ich glaube wirklich
außer heraushängen lassen meine jump
skills seiner jahr deswegen das mache
ich ja völlig ernst was ich gerade sei
gestört
ich muss das jetzt machen so komme ich
nicht weiter was sprungkraft nein ich
muss dem bleibt kaputt machen weil ich
auf dem baum so halb gelandet bin
ich bin fast ein fall schaden gestorben
weil ich sprung lust hatte lobe ich sehe
ihre kräfte wie süß ist den krankhafter
krank ich bin der crack kräfte der
strecke ab guck mal wo ich bin war nach
oben kommen nach oben kommt man jetzt
genau nach oben als auch mal immer alles
laufen morales ist dass man sich in
meinem leben da muss man einfach ich
mache das bild das liege entgegennehmen
damit noch mehr weiterkommt ändern
wie gesagt von yma speedrun um mein gott
bisher läuft sprungkraft alter cheetah
bisher läuft bei mir auch nicht hier
oben bleibt noch eine hübsche genau
überlegen genau über die genau über dir
genau über die also wirklich noch einmal
zügig mit speed run a
ich sage es nicht
was ist das für ein pac man und nebelig
schuldig wie ganz oben alter wie mich
das auftreten dieser eine sprung
wenn du jetzt darum rumgammeln ich habe
sie mal bereich jeden geschmissen
hier oben auf dem baum damit du
vielleicht auch mal auf den geschmack
kommt ohne spaß ich mache echt grad
heftigen speedway on z als sie sich
durch das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr datis denn was ist
los mit dir gott weiß nicht wann ich
nehme die abkürzung auch an bist du
leben
ich bin ich bin einfach die in sillian
hochgeklettert und doch ihr kollege
sonnenschein ein kleiner könnten
konzentriere ich mich mal das ok oh
hierzu zählt die rund 32 19 herzlich
jetzt bist du bei dem wir sagen da kann
ich auch nicht warten
durch den gesang weg laufen aber es geht
einfach nicht ich höre ihn einfach
überall hätten wir ein besonderes tool
hier auf diesem server und ich will
einfach schon richtig weite halten
schnauzte er ist so wenn du nicht siehst
du kriegst du bürger dafür sehe ich auf
jeden fall höchstgewicht siehst du mich
siehst du dich euro ja okay jetzt sehe
ich nur noch deine schrift hatte ich
habe aber eine spritze mich lustig ich
bin jetzt richtig schwach etwas runter
er ich weiß auch was hochfahren also
richtig cool zu sein
ich fange mit dem mund floss mit einem
hub noch welche direkt du jetzt komme
ich jetzt komme ich mag das
hier konnte man ist mit mir ich kann ich
nicht ein alter wenn ich hier oder falle
da ich bin einfach tot
alter ist das gerade scheiße mann nein
die folge ist aber gleich vorbei dann
hab ich diese folge auf nein
ja geil aber mit ich zeigt dass meine
taktik komme mit ich möchte zeigen wie
ich hier mal hoch gekommen ist will ich
war so weit dass sie meine taktiken dass
ich hab nichts abgebaut hier das war
alles schon in kürze von hier
da sodass ich habe die eigene taktik
entwickelt ja alles im alter ich habe
auch noch eine taktik vorstellungsrunden
gelang
da müssen wir gar nicht lange gespannten
doch andere richtung nein wenn wir
müssen auch in die höhle erst mal rein
bist du blöd nein nein bin ich nicht
wo siehst du in eine höhle kollege lorne
vorne
hier wo ich stehe eher geil ich sehe ich
nicht mal bist du hierher komme ich auf
boden ganz unten nochmal etwas geradeaus
nach vorne hier hinten hallo umdrehen
hier wo ich kann wieso willst du dann
oehler um hier ist der name da muss man
noch rein
von da kommen wir doku passat tuba
startup nein wir müssen hier lange spaß
hier und anna-lena priester die ganze
zeit jetzt nimmt sie auch schon eine
abkürzung gültig das leben dieser krise
richtig leben kommen jetzt hier lang
mensch ich muss wieder sehen sonst geht
das nicht naja ich auch glaube
halbes herz business service auch die
folge beenden meine lieben freunde ich
habe ich die ganze zeit nicht
teleportiert ich bin ein bisschen
weitergekommen aber auch ein bisschen
nicht und ich würde sagen die erste
folge ist bei komme auf dem kanal
falls es euch trotzdem gefallen hat auch
wenn jetzt nicht wirklich weitergekommen
hier
dann würde ich mich definitiv bei eine
normierung eurerseits freuen und
natürlich sagen sehen wir uns wieder
genau